[Applaudissements]
on va se parler d'histoire de confiance
perdue et de confiance retrouvée alors
moi en 2000 j'étais très heureuse après
plusieurs années passées dans la
communication
je montais ma propre agence j'avais un
associé très charismatique avec des
valeurs humaines élevé on a appelé notre
agence rouge c'est l agence des
solutions révolutionnaires alors comme
c'est l agence d re zde des solutions
révolutionnaires
on aimait bien se déguiser avec des
oripeaux de l'armée rouge et vous voyez
que la même avec un chapeau ridicule
moi j'avais la foi ont des grandes
marques nous ont fait confiance
microsoft entre autres et puis on a
grandi on était 2 puis on était 4 puis
on était 10 puis on était 20 30 50
alors on a voulu grandir encore et on a
fait une levée de fonds est l'aveu levée
de fonds a capoté
alors on a eu des dettes beaucoup de
dettes alors on a mis le turbo sur les
compétitions les compétitions c'est un
système très toxique pour les agences
qui consiste à travailler gratuitement
et sans garantie de résultat on s'est
épuisé
on était exsangue et moi je me posais
beaucoup de questions sur mon métier je
me disais mais à quoi ça sert de faire
consommer les gens toujours plus à quoi
ça sert de leur demander toujours plus
d'engagement pour des sujets qui sont
sans intérêt en 2013 dans les remous
d'internet crise on tombe en
redressement judiciaire nous les
associés on avait tous des grosse
caution personnelle sur la tête
il fallait trouver une solution on fait
le tour du marché
on se rapproche du troisième groupe de
communication français c'est des
entrepreneurs ici on bienveillant ils
sont innovants ils sont dynamiques ils
veulent de nous on finalise un deal
alors c'est fantastique maintenant on
est dans un
en groupe il ya une nouvelle époque qui
s'annonce eh bien non là c'est moi qui
mets fondre tout vole en éclats ma
famille mon couple j'ai plus confiance
je me sens nul et puis je trouve que le
monde est nul aussi je le trouve dur je
le trouve injuste je le trouve
indéchiffrable c'est la nuit noire de
l'âme et comme souvent dans ces périodes
quand vraiment tout va mal c'est des
rencontres c'est des rencontres qui
représente des lumière au bout du tunnel
alors pour moi la première rencontre
c'est mon frère gilles alors jlm alençon
il est scénariste et pour les besoins
d'un scénario je crois il s'était formé
à l'hypnose et il m'a dit tu sais tu
devrais aller regarder de ce côté là
l'hypnose c'est une attention accordée à
la subjectivité
alors moi la subjectivité c'est un peu
tout ce que j'avais laissé de côté dans
ma vie les états de conscience modifié
les rêves les émotions les intuitions le
non verbal
je suis donc allé me former avec jean
dupré et kevin fine elles qui sont mes
deuxièmes et troisièmes lumière à la
communication hypnotique c'est-à-dire
l'hypnose mise au service des techniques
de communication
la gt avec plein de gens très différents
il y avait des thérapeutes bien sûr il y
avait des étudiants
il y avait des coachs mais il y avait
aussi beaucoup de négociateurs de tous
ordres il y avait des start-up heures il
y avait des policiers et avait des
syndicalistes
là j'ai appris une chose très importante
moi c'est que le monde est le fruit de
nos représentations ce que je peux vous
dire avec objectivité sur l'objectivité
c'est que l'objectivité n'existe pas
pour cette raison là nous sommes
subjectif vous faites
l'hypnose c'est un petit peu comme mon
cinéma quand on s'installe on voit un
film c'est vrai ou c'est pas vrai mais
en fait on y croit et c'est ça qui
compte
et puis comme au cinéma ce serait
bible d'être obligé de voir toujours le
même film n'est ce pas et bien en
hypnose j'apprends une chose c'est que
si les représentations que je me fais du
monde ne me conviennent pas eh bien je
suis libre d'en changer
je suis libre d'en changer et on nous
apprend à faire le tri entre les
croyances à les identifier et à retenir
celles qui sont utiles pour soi retenir
les croyances qui sont utiles pour soi
changer de représentation je commence à
revoir le film de mon échec et je
commence à mettre en avant les côté
lumineux et là il y à un quatrième
personnage qui arrive mon frère gilles
toujours qu'ils jouent dans cette
affaire le rôle d'éveilleur de
conscience et qui a un attrait pour les
choses un peu bizarre me met dans les
mains un livre c'est un livre de
physique
alors moi vous savez je suis littéraire
100% donc la physique mais bon je lis
quelques pages et puis on décide d'aller
voir en conférence un certain philippe
guillemant chercheur au cnrs lui ce
qu'ils cherchent à faire s'est posée
l'existence de la conscience avec les
outils de la physique on arrive sur le
lieu de la conférence
il ya plus de place il ya plus de place
on est très dépité
on est venus de loin on se replie sur un
café attenant à la salle de conférence
et puis il se trouve que derrière nous
il y avait un monsieur avec une queue de
cheval un grand chapeau et puis on parle
on sympathise et le monsieur c'est
philippe guillemant lui même qui non
seulement nous invite à sa conférence
mais en plus on dînait avec lui après là
j'apprends plusieurs choses la première
chose que j'apprends c'est que ce que je
crois être le vide n'est pas du vide
en fait le vide est rempli d'énergie il
y aurait même 10 puissance 120 x + 2
vide dans le vide que dans la matière
alors moi tout de suite je visualise le
vide comme un océan rempli de vibrations
énergétique qui interagissent en
permanence avec elle je demande pardon
aux scientifiques
mon cerveau littéraire là est en train
d'interpréter ce que j'ai entendu en
physique et puis de quelle nature sont
ces interactions
en fait ces interactions elles
représentent des possibles elles
représentent même toutes les possibles
possible en fait cet océan et les
remplie d'événements potentiel compensée
par des antilles événements potentiels
le tout donne encore réalisé bon donc le
vide n'est pas vide et ce qui n'est pas
arrivé
et quand même un petit peu arriver je
trouve ce monde décidément très bizarre
dans les outils de recherche de philippe
guillemot lui il utilise le billard en
fait il met ensemble des milliers de
boules de billard pour calculer leurs
trajectoires et leur collision
le tout avec des algorithmes très
puissant voilà un petit peu comme ça et
puis là il se rend compte d'une chose il
se rend compte qu'au bout de centaines
de milliers de trajectoire le
déterminisme laisse place à quelque
chose d'intéressant
l'hypothèse qu'il pose c'est que
l'univers est là par convention à
j'appelle l'univers l'ensemble des
phénomènes qui nous entoure et qu'on
n'arrive pas à percevoir donc l'universe
actualiserait pour fermer des possibles
au fur et à mesure et en ouvrir d'autres
et qu'est-ce qui actualise rennes
l'univers est bien en partie nos
intentions et nos intentions c'est quoi
ce sont des pensées et ce sont des
émotions
donc quand je pose une intention eh bien
je densifie
sa probabilité d'arrivée lui il a une
drôle de formule pour ça ils appellent
ça excite et le vide
donc moi exciter le vide pour favoriser
l'occurrence du futur en l'occurence
j'avais l'impression d'avoir beaucoup
essayé d'avoir beaucoup essayé mais sans
vraiment beaucoup de résultats oui me
déguisements par l'intermédiaire de son
livre on se parle virtuellement par son
livre il me dit oui mais c'est que t'as
pas bien essayé en fait n'a pas bien
fait parce que d'une part quand on pose
une intention si on vibre d'une énergie
qui est différente si tu vibres
d'énergie de peur c'est une vive
d'énergie de colère situ et d'énergie de
tristesse comme tout ça et énergétique
eh bien tu vas créer plus de cette même
énergie ensuite quand on pose une
intention ce qui est intéressant
après c'est de se détacher de
l'intention parce que si on se détache
de l'intention alors là on a des chances
de voir le futur des signes du futur le
futur arrivée et le futur ce sont des
synchronicité les synchronicité ce sont
des coïncidences non imposables qui sont
porteuses de l'intention de cet univers
comme par exemple philippe vivement qui
apparaît juste derrière nous au moment
où nous allons à sa conférence est où il
n'y a plus de place par exemple donc
après est ce que c'est le passé qui crée
le présent ou est ce que c'est le futur
qu'on va voir qui crée le présent je
pense que les deux sont vrais et chacun
ici dans cette salle doit avoir son
opinion là dessus
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que moi
avec ces deux découvertes qui sont
l'hypnose qui sont le panty à la fois
j'ai réussi à changer mes
représentations sur mon passé et a créé
aussi bas de l'énergie pour me recréer
un futur donc finalement tout ça comment
ça marche ça marche
un petit peu comme des lettres
d'intention vous savez je crois qu'on a
tous fait des lettres d'intention au
père noël non et bien ce que je vous
suggère c'est de poser une intention
c'est de vous définir l'avenir
2 vous le souhaitez le plus génial
possible épis de bien vous le visualiser
de bien visualiser des détails et puis
une fois que vous aurez visualiser mais
telle autre côté des tâches et vous du
résultat est là observez les signes du
futur en train de se mettre en marche
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]